اسمي تينا رحيمي ، أنا ملاكم
أسترالي والداي من أصول إيرانية
لكنني ولدت وترعرعت في
أستراليا
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى
] نشأت في أسرة غير
متدينة  لم أرتدي الحجاب
، فربما كانت بعض التحديات التي واجهتها هي
عدم ارتياحي للمنافسة
في الرياضة مع الحجاب لأنه لا يوجد
الكثير من
الملاكمات
اللاتي يتنافسن بالحجاب أو في
الرياضة بشكل عام فقط ، فأنت تعرف الناس الذين
ينظرون إلي لأنني  أنا أرتدي ملابس
مختلفة عن الآخرين ، ونعم فقط
الأشخاص الذين ينظرون إليّ
وأنت تعلم أنك
لا تصدق أنني ملاكم
بسبب الطريقة التي أرتدي بها ملابسي
لجذب الناس إلى عندما يقول الناس
شيئًا عني والذي
قد يجعلني أشعر  حزين أو
[موسيقى]
الآن بسبب الملاكمة أشعر بالثقة
في الخروج والتحدث إلى الناس
وأنت تعلم أنني لست
خجولًا بعد الآن لأظهر للناس
أنني مسلم وأنني ملاكم لذا أشعر  لقد
بنيت ثقة أكبر وأنا لا أفعل
لا تدع أي شخص أو
أي شيء يقوله أي شخص يؤثر علي بعد
الآن وأنا أرتدي حجابي بكل فخر
وأنا أعلم أنني لا أهتم إذا كان الناس يعرفون
بوضوح أنني مسلم
وأن الحجاب جزء
مني وأنا '  يسعدني أن تكون لديّ الثقة في
الخروج إلى هناك وتمثيل الإسلام
بحجابي على
[الموسيقى] ،
أعني أنه من الرائع أن تكون
مصدر إلهام للإناث الأخريات في جميع أنحاء
العالم
وأن تُظهر لهن أنه يمكنك فعل
أي شيء وليس لديك
هل تعلم أن تخلت عن دينك
لتعرف أنك
تمارس الرياضة أو تفعل شيئًا رائعًا
كما قلت في نهاية اليوم أنا لست
قدوة ، فأنا لست مثاليًا ، لكن من الجيد
أن تكون مصدر إلهام للآخرين
وصنعهم  أكثر ثقة في الخروج
بالحجاب وعدم الإحراج
من تمثيل نفسي
[موسيقى]
أنا سعيد جدًا ومشرّف بالفوز بالميدالية البرونزية ،
لكن
هدفي الأساسي هو أن أصبح بطلة وأحصل على
الميدالية الذهبية ، لكنني سأعمل بجد
للحصول على  الرياضة رقم واحد
لأنها حلمي وسيكون من الرائع
أن أفعلها  بالذهب في الألعاب الأولمبية ، لذلك هذا هو
هدفي الرئيسي في الوقت الحالي ، أنا سعيد جدًا
لوجودي في أستراليا وكان الجميع
داعمين للغاية أيضًا ولكن نعم ، أنا
سعيد جدًا بتمثيل أستراليا في
الأحداث الدولية